اهلا وسهلا مشاهدينا اليوم متواجدين في
مسرح سعودي على هذا المسرح سيتنافس
المتسابقين في المراحل النهائيه لكن حلقه
اليوم راح تكون مختلفه لانها متزامنه مع
يوم التاسيس سيقدم متسابقون مدري وطني
وموعودين بوصلات غنائيه من لجنه التحكيم
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله انا وصلت مراحل متقدمه في
السعوديه ايدل وانا سعيده باللي قاعد
اقدمه وان شاء الله يعني نحلفنا الحب
[موسيقى]
السعودي قادر هو محطه عبور عشان انطلق
بالشيء اللي ابغاه اللي هو الفن فمحطه
العبور والشيء اللي بيوصلني ان شاء الله
للفن هذا الطريق باذن الله
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله قعدت راح اقدم اعمال طبعا
واسوي اشياء يعني حق الجمهور اللي صورتلي
واللي دعمني فعشان كذا ان شاء الله نبيض
الوجه بعدين
[موسيقى]
يعني انا اتوقع انه هذا حلمي وحلم كل
المتسابقين اللي معايا انه اسمنا يلمع
وشكلنا يلمع ويحفظونا الجمهور زي ما حفظنا
احنا الجيل اللي قبلنا من الفنانين
السعوديين وغيرهم ان شاء الله ربي يوفقنا
جميعا لهذا الشيء
[موسيقى]
السعودي اعطانا ارض خصبه عشان بنبني عليها
اعمالنا ونجاحنا ان شاء الله في الايام
الجايه وخطه كثير فنيه باذن الله وراح
يسمعون الناس بعد حاجات كثير حاجات حلوه
تعجبهم ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
نحاول هنا في سعودي ايدل انه نطلع الفن
السعودي اللي هدفنا في المستقبل انه نكون
فنانين من ضمن كوكبه النجوم في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالعام وملكتنا الحبيبه بالف الف خير طبعا
الغالي ولعهد الامين بالف خير الله يحفظ
المملكه
[موسيقى]
لان حلقه اليوم تزامرت مع يوم التاسيس صار
فيها شيء استثنائي وهو ما في احد
المشاركين غادر منافسه وجميعهم تاهل
المرحله القادمه صباح العربي محمد خالد
الرياض